hello and welcome to the agenda
back in september parliament launched
its official
election campaign for the elections
mobilizing citizens in the run up the
election cesar's head to rome for the
fourth react conference and up for
discussion is quality of life in europe
can the eternal city find solutions to
food safety the environment and health
follow the debate with italian
environmentalists food experts and
academics live on parliament's website
and a quick mention of an
inter-parliamentary conference taking
place in brussels representatives from
national parliaments the commission and
the european parliament will discuss
economic governance
iran features big at next week's foreign
affairs committee meeting first up is a
public hearing on europe's strategy for
iran following talks in geneva on the
deal to curb iran's nuclear ambitions
last november iran agreed to campus
nuclear enrichment programme in return
for an easing of sanctions by the west
after the hearing also looked out for a
debriefing by green mep tara kronberg
following a visit by parliament's
delegation to iran in tehran back in
mid-december
two big areas of legislation could
finally be wrapped up by the environment
committee first up the clinical trials
meps will vote to endorse negotiations
reached on a new regulation they will
see better rules and better protection
of patients
next up is the overhaul of tobacco laws
greenlighted back in december it sees
regulation of e-cigarettes and of 65 of
all packaging to carry a health warning
time for the committee to rubber-stamp
both deals so that they can go to a
final vote at the plenary and also over
a million tons that's the amount of
hazardous waste that member states
produce on average every year
europe prohibits the export of such
waste to non-oecd countries but hundreds
of illegal shipments still get through
the environment committee votes to
improve enforcement
and finally a broken peace deal may have
put an end to fighting that has killed
thousands but what next for the central
african republic with the un and other
humanitarian authorities calling on the
international community to act
parliament's development committee will
look at ways it can help the millions
displaced by the conflict as well as
continuing discussions on the ongoing
crises in syria and south sudan and
that's all we have from this agenda from
strasbourg take care and enjoy the week